first on CBS mornings we are very
excited to have the experts at the
points guy here reveals some winners of
their best of the best for travel in
2022 travel doesn't have to be so bad
they say the Points Guy awards ceremony
will be held tomorrow right here in New
York City honoring who hotels Airlines
and more the categories include this
best credit card perk like that best
affordable hotel brand best luxury Clues
Cruise Line and with us now are the
Points Guy founder and CEO that's Brian
Kelly and the Points Guy UK Nikki Calvin
good morning to you both Nikki special
welcome to you because you're a real boy
normally we only see you so it's nice to
see you actually have legs and it's nice
to have legs and shoes yes we're cheeky
you must be Wireless in Charlotte last
time I'm here with you I know I know I
remember that's right but both you guys
described yourself as uh plain Geeks you
know the configuration of the plane Nick
even says he has a favorite seat that he
wants to sit in I want to talk about
that a little bit later on so you know
this industry very well and so you're
looking at the best hotel loyalty
program who comes out on top so Nick you
want to take this one okay it's the best
hotel Lloyds program it's Marriott
bomvoy I need to make sure I get
Marriott rights yes right yes you did
you did we did a whole thing about how
to pronounce it so they won out because
they have 30 different brands that's one
of the big wins with Marriott so when
you're part of the program you get
access to lots of different uh lots of
different Pro lots of different brands
you can also get domestic and
international properties that all over
the world so I've used points to stay at
the W and the Maldives for example I'm
staying right now at Moxie around the
corner they have everything from the
really fun smaller Brands to the big
Swanky ones like Saint Regis and and it
is terrific and you can rack up uh the
the Bon void points on the campaign
Trail or on road coverage obviously in a
big city I'll just add so this week in
New York hotel prices are crazy a
thousand dollars and up for even the
cheapest hotel I used for my assistant
who wanted to come to the awards
tomorrow a free night from my credit
card that has a hundred dollar annual
fee and the hotel was a thousand dollars
a night wow so you can get huge value to
look at the free nights that come with
the hotel cards when it comes to Flying
best loyalty program for an airline so
Delta won the top spot this year that's
at bastian's play yeah so Delta you know
in the in the dark days of the pandemic
they were the first loyalty program to
extend Elite status now if you're a
frequent flyer you live and Breathe by
your lead status and people you know we
were worried about a pandemic but a lot
of frequent Travelers like what about my
Elite status and Delta was the first one
to say hey look we're going to continue
it for everyone and then the rest of the
industry followed and I just have to say
Delta you know when most Airlines might
give you a voucher when you wanted to
cancel during the pandemic Delta went a
step further in so many cases they'd
actually give you your money back the
ultimate Investments there that are
going to have long-term loyalty
something else Delta did in my household
Katie was diamond and then she went on
maternity leave and so she didn't travel
and she let them know and they extended
her status
right yeah nice well you mentioned
credit cards uh best travel rewards
credit cards so uh Chase Sapphire
preferred so that's a 95 card great
travel you know whenever anyone asks
what's the card I need to get I'm like
you can't go wrong with Chase Sapphire
but it's not just the points you know
this summer we saw those thousands of
cancellations Chase actually has flight
delay and cancellation coverage so as
long as you use that Sapphire card to
pay for your flight even if the airline
doesn't cover your hotel if you get
stranded your credit card will so I
always tell people look at the perks not
just the points on your credit card so
Nikki where do people want to go this
winter what are the hot destinations so
one place because you've been there
actually the place I'm going to start
with is somewhere where I've never been
I've been to Australia but I've never
been to Sydney
um there are direct flights starting to
Auckland and then onto Sydney from the
U.S so from New York it's going to be
much easier to get there Australia was
had a really strict lockdown the borders
were closed yeah and it's a it's a
country where there's so much to do and
so much to see but there's some really
exciting stuff coming up February and
March World Pride is going to be in
Sydney I've been to World Pride actually
in New York and if that's anything to go
by it's going to be a good one and the
FIFA World Cup will be um for women will
be next summer in Sydney as well so a
really great one so get a get a leg up
on that and check it out Brian you know
holiday travel season coming up when we
were in the break you said travel does
not have to be some so bad there's some
really bright spots out there so as
we're preparing to travel heavily what's
your advice the number one thing you've
got you've got to prepare
um you know if you're driving to the
airport pay for parking airports now
will even let you reserve your spot in
the security line and yeah you can
actually a lot of airports clear now has
a service where you can reserve your
spot take that stress out of it you know
get global entry and pre-check but look
try Thanksgiving travel went off without
a hitch you know so I'm traveling I'm
actually traveling on Christmas day
that's another uh tip you know a lot of
people like the day before after you
don't mind the actual yeah going to
Belize for the first time which is
supposed to be amazing so travel can be
done just pack a good attitude don't
assume that it's going to be horrible
right just do a little bit of planning
all right who are you taking the Belize
taking my eight week old son
he won't be scuba diving yet but uh no
more questions
Guy Brian Kelly and Points Guy UK Nikki
Kelvin thank you guys for being here